The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today's topic
is liquid gas condensation
and throughout this
course I have already
mentioned two
different perspectives
on the same
phenomenon, transition
between liquid and gas.
One perspective was when we
looked at the phase diagram
even in the first
lecture I mentioned
that if you look at
something like water
as a function of
pressure and temperature
it can exist in three
different phases.
There is the gas
phase, which you
have at high temperatures
and low pressures.
At low temperatures
and high pressures
you have the liquid phase.
And of course at
very low temperatures
you also have the possibility
of the solid phase.
And our concern
at some point was
to think about the location of
the coexistence of the three
phases of that was set as
the basis of the temperature,
273.16.
Actually what you're
going to focus now
is not this part of
the phase diagram
but the portion that consists
of the transition between liquid
and gas phases.
And this coexistence
line actually
terminates at what is called
the critical point that we will
talk about more today at the
particular value of Tc and Pc.
An equivalent perspective
that we have looked at that
and I just want to make sure
that you have both of these
in mind and know the
relationship between them
is to look at isotherms.
Basically we also
looked at cases
where we looked at isotherms
of pressure versus volume.
And this statement was that
if we look at the system
at high enough temperatures and
low enough pressures so let's
say pick this temperature and
scan along a line such as this,
it would be equivalent
over here to have
some kind of an isotherm that is
kind of potentially a distorted
version of an ideal
gas hyperbola.
Now if we were to look
at another isotherm
that corresponds to
this scan over here then
what would happen is
that it will cross
this line of the
coexistence, part of it
would fall in the
liquid phase, part of it
would fall in the gas phase.
And we draw the
corresponding isotherm,
it would look
something like this.
There would be a
portion that would
correspond to being
in the liquid.
There would be a
portion that would
correspond to being in the gas.
And this line, this point
where you hit this line
would correspond
to the coexistence.
Essentially you could change
the volume of a container
and at high volumes, you
would start with entirety gas.
At the same pressure
and temperature
you could squeeze it
and some of the gas
would get converted
to liquid and you
would have a coexistence
of gas and liquid
until you squeezed it
sufficiently, still maintaining
the same pressure
and temperature
until your container
was fully liquid.
So that's a different
type of isotherm.
And what we discussed
was that basically there
is a coexistence
boundary that separates
the first and the second
types of isotherms.
And presumably in between
there is some trajectory
that would correspond to
basically being exactly
at the boundary and it would
look something like this.
This would be the trajectory
that you would have at Tc.
The location Pc is
the same, of course,
so basically I
can carry this out
so there is the same Pc
that would occur here.
And there would be
some particular Vc
but that depends on the amount
of material that I have.
OK?
So we are going to try to
understand what is happening
here and in particular
we note that suddenly we
have to deal with cases
where there are singularities
in our thermodynamic parameters.
There's some
thermodynamic parameter
that I'm scanning as I
go across the system.
It will not be
varying continuously.
It has these kinds of
discontinuities in it.
And how did discontinuities
appear and how can
we account for these
phase transitions
given the formalisms
that we have developed
for studying
thermodynamic functions.
And in particular
let's, for example,
start with the canonical
prescription where I state,
let's say that I have volume
and temperature of a fixed
number of particles and
I want to figure out
thermodynamic properties
in this perspective.
What I need to calculate
is a partition function
and we've seen that the
partition function is obtained
by integrating over all degrees
of freedom which are basically
the coordinates and momentum
of particles that make up
this gas so I have
to do d cubed p i,
d cubed q i, divide by h cubed,
divide by n factorial because
of the way that we've been
looking at things, of energy
so I have e to the minus
beta h that has a part that
is from the kinetic energy which
I can integrate immediately.
And then it has a part that
is from the potential energy
of the interactions among
all of these particles.
OK?
So somehow if I could
do these integrations--
we already did them for
an ideal gas and nothing
special happened
but presumably if I
can do that for the case of
an interacting gas, buried
within it would be the
properties of this phase
transition and the
singularities, et cetera.
Question is how
does that happen?
So last time we tried
to do shortcuts.
We started with calculating a
first derivative calculation
in this potential and
then try to guess things
and maybe that was
not so satisfactory.
So today we'll take
another approach
to calculating this
partition function where
the approximations and
assumptions are more
clearly stated and we
can see what happens.
So I want to calculate
this partition function.
OK?
So part of that
partition function
that depends on the momentum I
can very easily take care of.
That gives me these
factors of 1 over lambda.
Again as usual my lambda
is h over 2 pi m k T
and then I have to do
the integrations over all
of the coordinates, all of
these coordinate integrations
and the potential that I'm
going to be thinking about,
so again in my U
will be something
like sum over pairs
V of q i minus q j,
where the typical form of this V
as a function of the separation
that I'm going to
look at has presumably
a part that is hard-core
and a part that is attract.
Something like this.
OK?
So given that potential what
are the kinds of configurations
I expect to happen in my system?
Well, let's see.
Let's try to make a diagram.
I have a huge number of
particles that don't come very
close to each other, there's
a hard-core repulsion,
so maybe I can think of them
as having some kind of a size--
marbles, et cetera, and they are
distributed so that they cannot
come close to each other.
More than that are
zero and then I
have to sum over all
configurations that
are compatible where they
are not crossing each other
and calculate e to
the minus beta u.
So let's try to do some kind
of an approximation to this u.
I claim that I can write this
U as follows- I can write it
as one-half, basically
this i less than j,
I can write as one-half
all i not equal to j,
so that's where the
one-half comes from.
I will write it as one-half
but not in this form,
as an integral d cubed
r d cubed r prime n of r
n of r prime v of r minus
r prime where n of r
is sum over all particles asking
whether they are at location r.
So I can pick some
particle opposition here--
let's call it r-- ask whether or
not there is a particle there,
construct the density by
summing over everywhere.
You can convince
yourself that if I
were to substitute
this back over here,
the integrals over r
and r prime can be done
and they sit r and r prime
respectively to sum q i and q j
and I will get back the
sum that I had before.
OK?
So what is that thing doing?
Essentially it says
pick some point, r,
and then look at some
other point, r prime,
ask whether there are
particles in that point
and then sum over all pairs
of points r and r prime.
So I changed my perspective.
Rather than calculating the
energy by looking at particles,
I essentially look
at parts of space,
ask how many
particles there are.
Well, it kind of makes
sense if I coarse-grained
this a little bit that
the density should
be more or less the same
in every single box.
So I make the assumption
of uniform density--
I shouldn't say
assumption, let's
call it an approximation of
uniform density in which I
replace this n of r
by it's average value
which is the number of
particles per [INAUDIBLE].
OK?
Then my U-- I will
take the n's outside.
I will have one-half n
squared integral d cubed
r d cubed r prime v
of r minus r prime.
Again it really is a function
of the relative distance
so I can integrate
over the center of mass
if you like to get
one factor of volumes
so I have one n
squared V and then
I have an integral
over the relative
coordinate d cubed r-- let's
write it as 4 pi r squared d
r, the potential as a
function of separation.
Now the only configurations
that are possible
are ones that don't really
come closer than wherever
the particles are on
top of each other,
so really there is some kind
of a minimum value over here.
The maximum value you could
say is the size of the box
but the typical range of
potentials that we are thinking
is much, much less than
the size of the box.
So for all intents
and purposes I
can set the value of the other
part of the thing to infinity.
So what I'm doing is essentially
I'm integrating this portion
and I can call the result
of doing that to be minus u.
Why minus?
Because it's clearly
the attractive portion
in this picture I'm integrating.
And you can convince yourself
that if I use the potential
that I had before-- yes,
the last time around it
was minus u 0 r 0 over
r to the sixth power,
but this u is actually the
omega that I was using times u 0
but I will keep it as
u to sort of indicate
that it could be a
more general potential.
But the specific potential that
we were working with last time
to calculate the second
visual coefficient
would correspond to that.
So essentially I claim
that the configurations
that I'm interested
will give a contribution
to the energy which is
minus whatever this u 0--
u is n squared V divided by 2.
Now clearly not
all configuration
has the same energy.
I mean that's the
whole thing, I have
to really integrate
overall configurations.
I've sort of looked at
an average contribution.
There will be configurations
where the particles are
more bunched or separate,
differently arranged,
et cetera, and
energy would vary.
But I expect that
most of the time--
I see something like
a gas in this room,
there is a uniform
density typically.
The fluctuations in
density I can ignore
and I will have a
contribution such as this.
So this factor I will replace
by what I have over here.
What I have over here will
give me e to the minus
beta u density squared actually
I can write as N squared
over V squared, one of V's
cancel here, I have 2 V. OK?
So that's the typical value of
this quantity but now I have
to do the integrations
over all of the q's.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In terms of the
approximation you made--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --the implications are
that if you have a more complex
potential--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --you'll get into
trouble with for a given sample
size, it will be less accurate.
would you agree with that?
PROFESSOR: What do you mean
by a more complex potential?
Until you tell me, I can't--
AUDIENCE: I mean I, guess,
and usually-- I mean,
I guess if you had like
multi-body or maybe
the cell group.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So certainly what I have assumed
here is a two-body potential.
If I had a three-body
potential then I
would have a term that
would be density cubed, yes.
AUDIENCE: But then you would--
my point is that-- and maybe
it's not a place to question--
for a given sample size,
I would imagine there's some
relation between how small
it can be and the complexity
of the potential when you make
this uniform density assumption.
PROFESSOR: OK.
We are always evaluating things
in the thermodynamic limit,
so ultimately I'm always
interested in m and v going
to infinity, while the
ratio of n over v is fixed.
OK?
So things-- there are certainly
problems associated with let's
say extending the range of
this integration to infinity.
We essentially are
not worrying about
the walls of the
container, et cetera.
All of those effects
are proportional to area
and in the thermodynamic limit,
the ratio of area to volume
goes to zero.
I can ignore that.
If I bring things to
become smaller and smaller,
then I need to worry
about a lot of things,
like do particles absorb
on surfaces, et cetera.
I don't want to do that.
But if you are worrying
about complexity
of the potential such as I
assume things to be radially
symmetric, you
say, well actually
if I think about
oxygen molecules,
they are not vertical.
They have a dipole-dipole
interactions potentially,
et cetera.
All of those you can take care
of by doing this integral more
carefully.
Ultimately the value of your
parameter u will be different.
AUDIENCE: But I guess what I'm
getting at is you deviate from
the-- if you're doing it-- if
we're back when computers are
not as fast and you can
essentially approach
the thermodynamic limit and
you're doing a simulation
and you want to use
these as a tool--
PROFESSOR: Mm-hmm?
AUDIENCE: --then you get
into those questions, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But this
framework should still work?
PROFESSOR: No.
This framework is
an approximation
intended to answer the
following question--
how is it possible that
singularities can emerge?
And we will see
shortly that the origin
of the emergence
of singularities
is precisely this.
And if I don't have that, then
I don't have singularities.
So truly when you do
a computer simulation
with 10 million particles, you
will not see the singularity.
It emerges only in the
thermodynamic limit
and my point here is to sort
of start from that limit.
Once we understand
that limit, then maybe
we can better
answer your question
about limitations of
computer simulations.
OK?
So I've said that there's
basically configurations
that typically give
the [INAUDIBLE].
But how many configurations?
I can certainly move
these particles around.
And therefore I have to see what
the value of these integrations
are.
OK?
So I will do so, as follows--
I will say that the first
particle, if there
was nobody else--
so I have to do this
integration over q 1, q 2, q 3,
and I have some constraints in
the space that the q's cannot
come closer to each
other than this distance.
So what I'm going to
try to calculate now
is how this factor of v to the
n that you would have normally
put here for ideal
gases gets modified.
Well I say that the first
particle that I put in the box
can explore the entire space.
If I had two particles,
the second particle
could explore everything
except the region that
is excluded by the
first particle.
The second particle
that I put in
can explore the space
minus the region that
is excluded by the
first two particles.
And the last, the end
particle, the space
except the region
that is excluded
by the first n minus 1.
This is an approximation, right?
So if I have three
particles, the space
that is excluded for
the third particle
can be more than this
if the two particles
are kind of close to each other.
If you have two
billiard balls that
are kind of close to each
other the region between them
is also excluded for
the first particle.
We are throwing that out and
one can show that that is really
throwing out things
that are higher
order in the ratio of omega
over V So if you're right,
this is really an
expansion in omega over V
and I have calculated
things correctly
to order of omega over V.
And if I am consistent
with that and I multiply
all of these things together,
the first term is V to the N
and then I have 1 minus omega
plus 2 omega plus all the way
to N minus 1 omega which then
basically sums out to 1 plus 2
plus 3 all the way to N minus
1, which is N minus 1 over 2
in the large N limit.
It's the same thing
as N squared over 2
and this whole thing is
raised to the power-- OK
this whole thing I can
approximate by V minus N
omega over 2 squared.
There are various
ways of seeing this.
I mean one way of seeing this
is to pair things one from one
end and one from the
other end and then
multiply them together.
When you multiply
them you will have
a term that would go be
V squared, a term that
would be proportionate
to V omega
and would be the sum of
the coefficients of omega
from the two.
And you can see that
if I pick, say, alpha
term from this
side N minus alpha
minus one term from
the other side,
add them up, the alphas
cancel out, N and N minus 1
are roughly the same, so
basically the square of two
of them is the same as
the square of V minus N
omega over 2.
And then I can repeat that
for all pairs and I get this.
Sorry.
So the statement is that
the effect of the excluded
volumes since it is joint
effect of mutually excluding
each other is that V to the
N that I have for ideal gas,
each one of them can go
over the entire place,
gets replaced by V minus
something to the power of N
and that something
is N omega over 2.
Plus higher orders
in powers of omega.
OK?
So I will call this a
mean field estimate.
Really, it's an average
density estimate
but this kind of
approximation is typically
done for magnetic systems
and in that context
the name of mean
field has stuck.
And the ultimate result is that
my estimation for the partition
function is 1 over
N factorial lambda
to the power of 3 N V
minus N omega over 2
raised to the power of N
because of the excluded volume
and because of the Boltzmann
weight of the attraction
between particles
I have a term which
is e to the minus beta
U N squared over 2V.
OK?
So the approximations
are clear on what
set of assumptions I get this
estimate for the partition
function.
Once I have the
partition function,
I can calculate the
pressure because log z is
going to be related
to free energy,
the derivative of the free
energy respect to volume
will give me the pressure,
and you can ultimately
check that the formula
is that beta P is the log
Z by d V. That's
the correct formula.
And because we are doing this
in the canonical formalism
that I emphasized
over here, let's
call this P that we get through
this process beta P canonical.
OK?
So when I take log z,
there's a bunch of terms
and I don't really
care about because they
don't have V dependence
from N factorial lambda
to the power of 3N,
but I have N times log
of V minus N omega over 2.
So that has V dependence.
Take the derivative of log
of V minus N omega over 2,
what do I get?
I get V minus N omega over 2.
The other theorem
when I take the log
I have a minus beta
U N squared over 2 V
so then I take a
derivative of this 1
over V. I will
get minus 1 over V
squared so I have
a term here which
is beta U over 2 N
squared over V squared.
OK?
Let's multiply by
k T so that we have
the formula for P canonical.
P canonical is then N k
T V minus N omega over 2
and then I have-- I think I made
a sign over here-- yes the sign
error that I made
is as follows-- note
that the potential is attractive
so I have a minus U here.
So when I exponentiate
that, it becomes a plus here
and will be a plus
here and therefore I
will have a minus here
and I will have a minus U
over 2 times the
density squared.
OK?
So what did we arrive at?
We arrived at the van
der Waals equation.
OK?
So we discussed
already last time
around that if I now look
at the isotherms pressure
volume at different
temperatures,
at high temperatures
I have no problem.
I will get things that look
reasonable except if I have
to terminate at something that
is related to this excluded
volume, whereas if I go to
low temperatures, what happens
is that the kind of
isotherms that I get
have a structure which
is kind of like this
and incorporates a region
which violates everything
that we know about
thermodynamics,
is not stable, et cetera.
OK?
So what happened here?
I did a calculation.
You can see every step of
the calculation over there.
Why does it give me nonsense?
Everything that you need
to know is on the board.
Suggestions?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: The assumption
of uniform density
in a phase transition?
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's the picture
that I put over here.
If I draw the box that
corresponds to what
is happening over there,
what's going on in the box?
So there is a box.
I have particles in it
and in the region where
this nonsense is
happening, what is actually
happening in reality?
What is actually
happening in reality
is that I get some
of the particles
to condense into
liquid drops somewhere
and then there's
basically the rest
of them floating
around as a gas.
Right?
So clearly I cannot, for this
configuration that I have over
here, calculate energy
and contribution this way.
So coexistence implies
non-uniform density.
OK?
So what do we do?
I want to carry out
this calculation.
I want to stay as
much as possible
and within this framework
and I can do it,
but I need to do
one other thing.
Any suggestions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Try to describe
both densities simultaneously?
PROFESSOR: Try to
describe both densities--
AUDIENCE: You know
the amount of liquid
and the amount of
vapor on average--
PROFESSOR: I guess I could.
I have an easier
way of doing things.
OK.
So the easier way that
I have on doing things
is we have emphasized
that in thermodynamics, we
can look at different
perspectives.
Problem with this
perspective of the canonical
is that I know that I will
encounter this singularity.
I know that.
There's phase diagrams
like this exist.
Whereas if I use this
prescription I have one.
So what's the difference
is this prescription
is better mind in terms of
pressure and temperature.
So what I want to
do is to replace
the canonical
perspective with what
I will call the isobaric-- it's
the Gibbs canonical ensemble.
In this context it's
called isobaric ensemble
where rather than describing
things at fixed volume,
I describe things
at fixed pressure.
So I tell you what
pressure, temperature,
and the number of
particles are and then
I calculate the corresponding
Gibbs partition function.
Why does that help?
Why that helps is because of
what you see on the left side
diagram is if I
wanted to maintain
this system at the
fixed pressure rather
than a fixed volume,
I would replace
one of the walls of this
container with a piston
and then I would apply a
particular value of pressure.
Then you can see that a
situation such as this
does not occur.
The piston will move
so that ultimately I
have a uniform density.
If I'm choosing my
pressure to be up here,
then it would be all liquid.
If I choose my pressure to be
down here, it will be all gas.
So I have this piston on top.
It does not tolerate
coexistence.
It will either keep
everybody in the gas phase
or it will compress,
change the volume
so that everybody becomes
liquid so what I have done
is I have gotten
rid of the volume.
And I do expect that
in this ensemble as I
change pressure and
go through this line,
there is a discontinuity that
I should observe in volume.
OK?
So again just think
of the physics.
Put the piston, what's
going to happen?
It's going to be either
one or the other.
And whether it is one or the
other, I'm at uniform density
and so I should be able to
use that approximation that I
have over there.
OK?
So mathematics,
what does that mean?
This Gibbs version
of the partition
function in this
isobaric ensemble,
you don't fix the volume
you just integrate over
all possible volumes weighted
by this e to the minus beta P V
that does the Laplace
transform from one ensemble
to the other of the
partition function
which is at some fixed
volume, V T N. OK?
And for this we use the
uniform density approximation.
So my Gibbs partition
function, function
of P T and N is the integral 0
to infinity d V e to the minus
beta P V and I guess I have
what would go over here
would be log Z of V T N. OK?
Again this is answer
to previous question,
I am in the thermodynamic limit.
I expect that this which gives
essentially the probabilities
or the weights of
different volumes
is going to be dominated
by a single volume that
makes the largest contribution
to the thermodynamics
or to this integration.
But this integration
should be subtle point
like so what I would do is I
will call whatever is appearing
here to be some function of V
because I'm integrating over V
and I'm going to
look for its extreme.
So basically I expect that this
because of this subtle point
will be e to the psi of V
that maximizes this weight.
OK?
So what I have to do is I
have to take the psi by d V
and set that to 0.
Well part of it is simply minus
beta P. The other part of it
is log Z by d V but the log
Z by d V I have up there.
It's the same Z that
I'm calculating.
It is beta P canonical.
So this is none
other than minus beta
the P that I in this
ensemble have set out,
minus this P canonical that
I calculated before which
is some function of the volume.
Again, generally, it's fine.
We expect the
different ensembles
to correspond to each
other and essentially that
says that most of the time
you will see that you're
going to get the pressure
calculated in this fashion
and calculated canonically
to be the same thing.
Except that sometimes we seem
to have ambiguity because what
I should do is given that I
have some particular value
of pressure that I emphasize
exists in my isobaric ensemble,
I calculate what
the corresponding V
is by solving this equation.
What is this
equation graphically?
It says pick your
P and figure out
what volume in these
canonical curves, intersected.
So the case that I drew
has clearly one answer.
I can go up here
I have one answer.
But what do I do when I have
a situation such as this?
I have three answers.
So in this ensemble I
say what the pressure is
and I ask, well,
what's the volume?
It says you should solve this
equation to find the volume.
I solve the equation
graphically and I
have now three
possible solutions.
What does that mean?
All this equation says is that
these solutions are extrema.
I set the derivative to 0.
The task here is to find if
I have multiple solutions,
the one that gives me the
largest value over here.
So what could be happening?
What is happening is
that when I'm integrating
as a function of
V, this integrand
which is e to psi of V. Right?
An integrand in the
curve let's call
these curves over
here number one.
In the case number one
there's a clear solution
is if I'm scanning in volume,
there is a particular location
that maximizes this side of V
and the corresponding volume
is unambiguous.
If I go and look
at the curve let's
say up here let's call it
that case number three.
For case number three it
also hits the blue curve
unambiguously at one point
which is at much lower volume
and so presumably
I have a situation
such as this for my number two.
Now given these
two cases it is not
surprising that the middle
one, let's say number two here,
corresponds to a situation
where you have two maximums.
So generically,
presumably, case number two
corresponds to
something such as this.
OK?
There are three solutions to
setting the derivative to 0.
There are three extrema.
Two extrema
correspond to maxima.
One extrema corresponds
to the minimum
and falls between the
two and clearly that
corresponds to this portion
that we say is unstable.
It's clearly unstable because
it's the least likely place
that you're going
to find something.
Right?
Not the least likely but if you
go a little bit to either side,
the probabilities
really increase.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think your
indices don't correspond
on the plot you've just
drawn and on the [INAUDIBLE].
Like 1, 2, 3 in parentheses,
in two different cases
they don't correspond to it.
PROFESSOR: Let's
pick number one.
AUDIENCE: Number
one is when we have
a singular maximum
is the biggest.
PROFESSOR: With the
biggest volume, yes?
AUDIENCE: No.
Number two should be--
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
That's right.
So this is number three
and this is number two.
And for number two I indicated
that there are maxima that I
labelled one, two, and three
without the parenthesis that
would presumably
correspond to these.
OK?
So then you see there
is now no ambiguity.
I have to pick
among the three that
occur over there, the three
solutions that correspond
that occur from the
van der Waals equation.
The one that would give the
highest value for this function
psi.
Actually what is psi if you
think about this ensemble?
This ensemble is going to
be dominated by minus beta P
V at the location of the
V that is thermodynamic.
This Z is e to the minus beta
E, so there's a minus beta E
and there's omega which
gives me a beta T S.
So it is this combination
of thermodynamic quantities
which if you go and look at your
extensivity characterization
is related to the
chemical potential.
So the value of the
psi at the maximum
is directly related to
the chemical potential
and finding which one of
these has the largest value
corresponds to which solution
has the lowest chemical
potential.
Remember we were drawing this
curve last time around where
we integrated van der
Waals equation to calculate
the chemical
potential and then we
have multiple solutions
for chemical potential.
We picked the lowest one.
Well, here's the justification.
OK?
All right.
So now what's happening?
So the question
that I ask is how
can doing integrals such as
this give you some singularity
as you're scanning in say
pressure or temperature
along the lines such as this?
And now we have the
mechanism because presumably
as I go from here to here
the maximum that corresponds
to the liquid volume will get
replaced with the maximum that
corresponds to the gas
volume or vice versa.
So essentially if you have
a curve such as two then
the value of your Z which is
also e to the minus beta U N
as we said is determined by the
contribution from here or here.
Well, let's write both of them.
I have e to the
psi corresponding
to the V of the gas plus
e to the psi corresponding
to V the liquid.
Now both of these
quantities are quantities
that in the large N limit
will be exponentially large.
So one or the
other will dominate
and the mechanism of
the phase transition
is that as I change
parameters, as I change my P,
I go from a situation
that is like this
to a situation
that is like this.
The two maxima change heights.
OK?
It is because you are
in the large N limit
that this can be expressed
either as being this
or as being the other
and not as a mixture
because the mixture you
can write it that way
but it's a negligible
contribution
from one or the other.
This is the answer I was giving
in connection with computer
simulations.
Computer simulations, let's
say you have 1,000 particles.
You have e to the 1,000 times
something, e to the 1,000
times another thing,
and if you, for example,
look at the curves for
something like the density
you will find that you will
start with the gas density.
You ultimately have to
go to the liquid density
in the true
thermodynamic limit there
will be a discontinuity here.
If you do a computer
simulation with finite end,
you will get a continuous
curve joining one to the other.
As you make your size of
your system simulated bigger,
this becomes
sharper and sharper,
but truly the
singularity will emerge
only in the N goes
to infinity limit.
So phase transitions, et
cetera, mathematically really
exist only for infinite
number of particles.
Well, of course, for
10 to the 23 particles
the resolution you
would need over
here to see that it's
actually going continuously
from one to the other
is immeasurably small.
OK?
Any questions about that?
I guess there was
one other thing
that maybe we should note.
So if I ask what is the
pressure that corresponds
to the location of
this phase transition,
so what is the value of
the pressure that separates
the liquid and gas, the
location of the singularity?
I would have to find Pc from
the following observation,
that that's the pressure
at which the two
psi's, psi of the
gas is the same thing
as the psi of the liquid.
Right?
All right.
Or alternatively, the difference
between them is equal to 0.
OK?
And the difference
between-- I can
write this kind of
trivially as the integral
of the derivative
of the function.
So d V d psi by d V integrated
between the V of the liquid
and then the V of the gas.
That integral should be 0.
d psi by d V we established,
is this quantity.
It is beta integral from
V liquid to V gas d V P
canonical of V minus this
P transition that I want,
has to be zero.
OK?
So what do I have to do?
Since that we identify the
location of your Pc such
that if you integrate the
canonical minus this Pc
all the way from the V of
the gas to V of the liquid,
this integral will give you 0.
So this is the
Maxwell construction
that you were using last time.
Again, it is
equivalent to the fact
that we stated that really this
object is the same or related
to the chemical potential, so
I'm requiring that the chemical
potential should be the same
as I go through the transition.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you repeat
why minus finite size
does not in phase transition?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yes.
So let's imagine that I
have two possibilities that
appear as exponentials but
the number that is appearing
in the exponential which is the
analog of N makes one of them
to be positive so I have
e to the N u and the other
to be negative.
So my object would be
something like this.
OK?
Then what is this?
This is related to a factor of
2 to hyperbolic cosine of N u.
OK?
So this is like some kind
of a partition function
and what we are
interested is something
like the log of this quantity.
And maybe if I take a
derivative with respect
to u of this I
will get something
like the tangent of N u.
OK?
So some kind-- something
like a tangent and u
would be something
like the expectation
value of this quantity.
It's either plus u
or minus u and it
occurs-- so the average of
it would be e to the N u
minus e to the minus N u e to
the N u plus e to the minus N u
and so u would be some
kind of an expectation
value of the quantity
such as this.
Now what is this function look
like the function tangent.
So for positive values it goes
to plus 1, for negative values
it goes to minus 1 and it's a
perfectly continuous function.
It goes to 0.
All right?
That's the tangent function.
Now suppose I calculate
this for N of 10,
this is the curve that I drew.
Suppose I draw this
same curve for N of 100.
For N of 100 I
claim that the curve
will look something like
this because the slope
that you have at the
origin for the tangent
grows like N so basically
becomes steeper and steeper
but ultimately has to
saturate one or the other.
So what-- for any, for even N of
1,000 then it's a finite slope.
The slope here is related to
1,000 U 1,000, but it's finite.
It is only in the
limit where N goes
to infinity you would say
that the function is either
minus 1 or plus 1
depending on whether U
is positive or negative.
So the same thing
happens as I scan over
here and ask what
is the density?
The density looks precisely
like this tangent function.
For finite values of
the number of particles
the density would do
something like this.
It is only for infinite
number of particles
that the density
is discontinuous.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sir, on the plot
which you drew initially
on that board, what are the
axis over which this scans?
PROFESSOR: Over here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Just what values
are physical values?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Pressure, right?
So what I said was that if
I scan across pressure what
I will see is a
discontinuity, right?
So if--
AUDIENCE: You said
that this is the result
of a numerical experiment with
finite number of particles.
So what is the parameter
of the experiment,
and what is the result.
PROFESSOR: We have the
density so you could have,
for example, exactly
the situation that I--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Pressure.
This box that I'm
showing you over here,
you simulate on the computer.
You have a box of finite volume,
you put a piston on top of it,
you simulate 1,000
particles inside.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR: Then you scan
as a function of pressure,
you plug the density.
Now, of course, if you
want to simulate this,
you have to increase both
the number of particles
and the volume of the box so
that the average density is
fixed and then you would
see something like this.
OK?
Any other questions?
OK, let's stick
with this picture.
I kind of focused on the
occurrence of the singularity,
but now let's see the exact
location of the singularity.
So I sort of started this
lecture by labeling Pc, Tc, Vc.
Well, what are their values?
OK.
So something that you
know from stability
is that the isotherms
are constrained such
that delta P delta V
has to be negative.
OK?
Or writing delta V as a
function of V or delta V,
this is d P by d V along an
isotherm delta V plus d 2
P by d V squared along
the isotherm delta
V squared-- this is one-half
plus one-sixth d cubed P d
V cubed along the
isotherm and so forth.
This whole thing
has to be negative.
OK?
Now generically I pick a point
and a small value of delta V
and the statement is
that along the isotherm
this derivative
has to be negative.
So generically what
I have is that d P
by d V for a physical
isotherm has to be negative
and indeed the reason we
don't like that portion
is because it violates
the stability condition.
Well, clearly that
will be broken
at one point the isotherm that
corresponds to T equals to Tc
is not a generic isotherm.
That's an isotherm that at some
point it comes in tangentially.
So there is over here a
point where d P by d V is 0
and we already discussed this.
If d P by d V is 0 then
the second derivative
in such an expansion
must also be 0.
Why?
Because if it is
nonzero, irrespective
of whether it is positive or
negative, since it multiplies
that V cubed, I will be
able to pick a delta V such
that the sine will be
violated by the delta V
of positive or
delta V of negative.
And clearly what it says is
that over here the simplest
curve that you can have
should not have a second order
therm which would
be like a parabola
but should be like a cubic.
And that the sine of the
cubic should be appropriate
the negative so that delta V to
the fourth is always positive,
then you have the right thing.
OK?
So given that information I
have sufficient parameters,
information to calculate what
the location of Pc, Tc, Vc
are for the van der Waals or
other approximate equation
of state such as
the one that you
will encounter in the problems.
So let's stick with
the van der Waals
so the van der Waals equation
is that my P is-- actually
let's divide by N so it
would be volume per particle
so I have introduced V to be
the volume per particle which
is the inverse of the
density, if you like,
so that is intensive.
V minus-- there's
some excluded volume,
let's call it
through the volume b
and then I have
minus something that
goes like the inverse
of this excluded volume,
let's write it as a.
Just I write those two
parameters as a and b
because I will be
taking many derivatives
and I don't want to write
anything more complicated.
OK.
So that's the equation.
We said that the location
of this critical point
is obtained by the
requirement that d P by d V
should be 0 so what is that?
It is minus k V T divided by
V minus b squared plus 2 a
over V cubed so I
took one derivative.
And the second derivative
is now constrained also,
so that's going to
give me plus 2 k T V
minus b cubed minus
6 a V to the fourth.
OK?
Now if I'm at a critical
point-- so I put c over here,
this will be 0, and
this will also be 0.
So the conditions for
the critical point
are that first of all k B Tc
divided by Vc minus b cubed
should be 2 a over
Vc cubed and 2
k B Tc Vc minus b to the
fourth power should be 6 a
divided by Vc to
the fourth power.
Hmm?
So this is two equations for two
unknowns, which are Tc and Vc.
We can actually reduce
it to one variable
by dividing these two
equations with each other.
The division of
the left-hand sides
will give me Vc minus b
in the numerator divided
by 2 in the denominator.
The ratio of these two
is simply Vc over 3.
That's a one variable equation.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Where you have
written the equations in terms
Vc minus b and Vc, it should
come in different powers.
So our first equation should
be Vc minus b squared.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Magically the ratio
does not get affected
and therefore neither
does the answer
which is Vc which is 3 b
so that's one parameter.
I can substitute that
Vc into this equation
and get what k B Tc is.
And hopefully you
can see that this
will become 2 b
squared, which is 4b
squared so this gives me a
factor of 8 a, ratio of these
will give me one factor
of b, so that's k B Tc.
And then if I substitute
those in the first equation,
I will get the value
of Pc and I happen
to know that the answer--
oops, this is going to be 27,
I forgot because 3
cubed will give me 27.
And Pc here will
give me 27 also.
I believe b squared a and
there will be a factor of 1.
OK.
OK?
Really the only
thing that actually I
wanted to get out
of this, you can
do this for any equation
of state, et cetera.
Point is that we
now have something
to compare to experiment.
We have a dimension less
ratio Pc Vc divided by k B Tc.
So I multiply these two
numbers, I will get one-ninth.
And then I have
here a factor of 8
so the whole thing becomes
a factor of 3 over 8
which is 0.375.
OK?
So the point is that we
constructed this van der Waals
equation through some
reasonable description of a gas.
You would imagine that
practically any type of gas
that you have will have some
kind of excluded volume so that
was one of the parameters
that we used in calculating
our estimation for the
partition function,
ultimately getting this omega.
And there's some kind of
attraction at large distance
that's been integrated
over the entire range,
here was this factor
of U. You would
expect that to be quite generic.
And once we sort of put
this into this machinery
that generic thing makes
a particular prediction.
It says that pick any gas,
find it's critical point--
critical point occurs
with for some value
of Pc density or
inverse density, Vc,
and some characteristic
[INAUDIBLE] pressure k B Tc.
This is a dimensionless ratio
you can calculate for any gas
and based on this
semi-reasonable assumption
that we made, no matter what
you do you should come up
the number that is around this.
OK?
So what you find in experiment?
You find that the values of this
combination from 0.28 to 0.33,
so that's kind of a range
that you find for this.
So first of all, you
don't find that it
is the same for all gases.
There is some variation.
And that it's not
this value of 3 8.
So there's certainly
now questions
to be asked about the
approximation, how
you could make it better.
You could say, OK,
actually most of the gases,
you don't have
spherical potentials.
You have things that
are diatomic that shape
may be important.
And so the estimation
that we have
for the energy for the omega
et cetera is too approximate.
There is something
to that because you
find that you get more or less
the same value in this range
for gases that are similar, like
helium, krypton, neon, argon,
et cetera, they're kind
of like each other.
Oxygen, nitrogen, these
diatomic molecules
are kind of like each other.
OK?
So there is some
hope to maybe get
the more universal description.
So what is it that we're after?
I mean the thing that is so
nice about the ideal gas law
is that it doesn't matter what
material you are looking at.
You make it
sufficiently dilute, you
know exactly what the
equation of state is.
It will be good if
we could extend that.
If we could say something
about interacting gases
that also maybe depends
on just a few parameters.
So you don't have to go
and do a huge calculation
for the case of
each gas, but you
have something that has the
sense of universality to it.
So clearly the van
der Waals equation
is a step in that direction,
but it is not quite good enough.
So people said,
well, maybe what we
should do is increase
the number of parameters,
because currently we are
constructing everything
based on two
parameters, the excluded
volume and some
integrated attraction.
So those are the two parameters
and with two parameters
you really can only
fit two things.
What we see that the ratio of
Pc Vc over k T is not fixed,
it's as a range, so
maybe what we should do
is to go to three parameters.
So this whole is
captured by the search
for law of corresponding states.
So the hope is that let's
do a three parameter system.
Which parameters
should I choose?
Well, clearly the
different systems
are characterized by Pc Tc
and Nc T at critical point,
so maybe what I should do is I
should measure all pressures,
made them dimensionless
by dividing by Pc
and hope that there is some
universal function that
relates that to the ratio of
all temperatures divided by Tc,
all densities or inverse
densities divided
by the corresponding Vc.
So is there such a curve so
that that was a whole and you go
and play around with this curve
and it is with this suggestion
and you can convince yourself
very easily that it cannot be
the case.
And one easy way
to think about it
is that if this
was the case, then
all of our virial
expansions and all
of the perturbative expansions
that we had should also
somehow collapse together
with a few parameters.
Whereas all of these
complicated diagrams that we
had with the cycles and
shapes and different things
of the diagrams are really,
you can calculate them.
They're completely
independent integrals.
They will give you
results that should not
be collapsible
into a single form.
So this was a nice suggestion
what in reality does not work.
So why am I telling you this?
The reason I'm
telling you this is
that surprisingly in the
vicinity of this point
it does work.
In the vicinity
of this point you
can get the huge number
of different system gases,
krypton, argon, carbon
dioxide, mixtures,
a whole lot of things.
And if you appropriately rescale
your pressure, temperature,
et cetera, for all
of these gases,
they come together and fall
on exactly the same type
of curve of over here.
OK?
So there is universality,
just not over the entire phase
diagram but in the vicinity
of this critical point.
And so what is special about
that, and why does that work?
OK?
So I give you first an
argument that says, well,
it really should work.
It shouldn't be a surprise.
And then show that the simple
argument is in fact wrong.
But let's go through because we
already put the elements of it
over there.
So let me try to figure out
what the shape of these pressure
versus volume curves are
going to be for isotherms that
correspond to different
temperatures close to Tc.
So what I want to
do is to calculate P
as a function of
volume, actually there's
reduced volume by the
number of particles,
and P and I'll do the following.
I will write this
as an expansion
but in the following
form-- P of Vc T plus d
P by d V at Vc T times V
minus, Vc plus one-half V 2
P by d V squared at Vc T minus
Vc squared plus one-sixth d
cubed P d V cubed at Vc and T
V minus Vc cubed and so forth.
So it's a function
of two arguments.
Really it has an expansion
in both deviations
from this critical point
along the V direction
so going away from Vc as
well as going T direction,
going to away from Tc but I
organize it in this fashion
and realize that actually
these derivatives and all
of the coefficients will be
a function of T minus Tc.
So for example P
of Vc and T starts
with being whatever value I
have at that critical point
and then if I go to higher
temperatures the pressure will
go up.
So there's some coefficient
proportional to T minus Tc
plus higher order in T minus
Tc and so forth and actually I
expect this alpha
to be positive.
The next coefficient d P by
d V Vc T T what do I expect?
Well, right at this point
d P by d V there's slope.
This has to be 0 for
the critical isotherm.
So it starts with 0 and
then if I go and look
at a curve that corresponds
to high temperatures because
of the stability, the
slope better be positive.
So I have a T minus
Tc plus our order
that I know that a is
positive because of a-- a
is negative because
of stability.
So let's write it
in this fashion.
OK?
What about the
second derivative?
Well, we said that if
I look at the point
where the first derivative is
0, the second derivative better
be 0, so it starts also with 0.
And then there's some
coefficient to order
of T minus Tc and
then higher order
and actually I don't know
anything about the sign of P.
It can be both
positive or negative,
we don't know what it is.
Now the third derivative
there is no reason
that it should start at 0.
It will be some negative
number again in order
to ensure stability and there
will be higher order terms
in T minus Tc what we have
is structure such as this.
So putting everything
together the statement
is that if I look in the
vicinity of the critical point,
ask what should
pressure look like?
You say, OK, it has to
start with a constant
that we called Pc.
It has this linear increase
that I put over there.
The first derivative
is some negative number
that is proportional to T minus
Tc multiplying by V minus Vc.
The third coefficient
is negative-- oh
and there's also a second--
there's the second order
coefficient and then there
will be high order terms.
So there should be generically
an expansion such as this.
Say, well, OK, fine,
what have we learned?
I say, well, OK, let me tell
you about something that we're
going to experimentally measure.
Let's look at the
compressibility, kappa.
Kappa is minus 1 over V d V
by d P evaluated at whatever
temperature you are looking at.
So if I look at this-- actually
I have stated what d P by d V
is.
d V by d P will be
the inverse of that,
so this is going to
give me in the vicinity
of this critical
point Vc a T minus Tc.
So the statement is
this is now something
that I can go and ask
my experimentalist
friends to measure,
go and calculate
the compressibility
of this gas, plot it
as a function of temperature,
and the prediction is
that the compressibility
will diverge at T goes to Tc.
OK?
So the prediction is that
it is 1 over a T minus Tc.
OK.
So they go and do
the experiment,
they do the experiment
for a huge number
of different systems,
not just one system,
and they come back
and say it is correct.
The compressibility does
diverge but what we find
is that irrespective of
what gas we are looking at,
and this is a very
universal, it goes
with an exponent like this.
OK?
So question is maybe you made
a mistake or you did something
or whatever, really
the big puzzle
is why do such different gases
all over the spectrum and even
some things that are not gases
but other types of things
all have the same diverges?
Where did this number
1.24 come from?
OK?
AUDIENCE: So there isn't a
range like there was 0.375.
It all depends on 1.24.
PROFESSOR: All hit 1.24.
Irrespective of
[? order. ?] It's
a different quantity, though.
I mean, it's not the
number, it's an exponent.
It's this, a functional form.
Why did this functional
form come about?
Another thing that
you predict is
the shape of the curve at Tc.
So what we have said is
that at T close to Tc,
the shape of this isotherm is
essentially that P minus Pc is
cubic, it's proportional
to V minus Vc cubed.
And the way that we said
that is OK at that point
there's neither a slope
nor a second derivative,
so it should be cubic.
They say, OK, what do
you find in experiment?
You go and do the
experiment and again
for a whole huge range of
materials all of the data
collapses and you find the curve
that is something like this,
is an exponent that
is very close to 5
but is not exactly 5.
And again, why not 3 and why
is it always the same number 5?
How do you understand that?
Well, I'll tell you why not 3.
Why not 3?
All of the things
that I did here
was based on the
assumption that I
could make an
analytical expansion.
The whole idea of
writing a Taylor series
is based on making
an analytical series.
Who told you that you can
do an analytic series?
Experiment tells you
that it is actually
something non-analytic.
Why this form of
non-analyticity?
Why it's universality?
We won't explain in this course.
If you want to find
out come to a 334.